[Music]
on this sunday night a global news
exclusive
i
felt somewhat betrayed by that letter
personally reaction to a top military
commander making the case to get his job
back after an allegation of sexual
assault
alternate acknowledgement deeply
disappointed with the government of new
brunswick the fallout from new
brunswick's order to stop making
indigenous title acknowledgments
kidnapped in haiti the effort to help a
group of u.s and canadian missionaries
now in the hands of a gang
a filmmaking first touchdown confirmed
russian movie makers returned to earth
after a historic space station shoot
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the sexual misconduct
crisis facing the canadian military the
woman at the heart of an investigation
involving admiral art mcdonald is
speaking out about a letter he sent to
top officers in it mcdonald makes the
claim he's being cleared and should get
his job back he was under investigation
for allegedly assaulting navy lieutenant
heather mcdonald during an alcohol
fueled party on hmcs montreal while it
was docked in greenland on an
international exercise in 2010 admiral
art mcdonald was the task force
commander at the time our mercedes
stephenson sat down with navy lieutenant
heather mcdonald who came forward with
the allegation and has this exclusive
report
it felt like a very public
attack on my integrity
and
i was disappointed to say the least
navy lieutenant heather mcdonald says
she was shocked to see a letter from
canada's top admiral sent to military
brass publicly denying any sexual
misconduct and claiming military police
had exonerated him after an
investigation into whether he sexually
assaulted her on a canadian warship i
was debriefed by cfnis and at no point
did they say that my statement was
unsubstantiated completely
or that he had been exonerated heather
mcdonald says she knows there are
witnesses who spoke to military police
and corroborated her allegation against
the admiral there were several witnesses
who did collaborate my story
at least one was the duty officer
so
he was sober and he did collaborate my
story an important fact on a night when
many allegedly said they were too drunk
to remember one or two
collaborations
were not quite enough to
compare to the many i don't remember it
was 10 years ago i'd been drinking i
didn't see it clearly global news spoke
to an eyewitness who was on board the
ship that night a naval officer who says
he clearly remembers what happened and
that heather mcdonald is telling the
truth that officer told global news he
gave a statement to military police
cooperating the allegations
admiral mcdonald is alleged to have
shoved the face of the ship's captain
into heather mcdonald's partially
exposed breasts after she lost a button
off her shirt military police said the
investigation did not produce evidence
to support the laying of charges did not
surprise me in the lease that
they are unable to charge or prosecute
the most senior
officer in the canadian armed forces
despite that she says the story was well
known and there are others who were
aware of what happened i know of at
least one person who had been using it
as a story to illustrate
the generational gap
of what is
ethical and moral while mcdonald feels
military police conducted a professional
investigation she thinks had the case
gone to civilian prosecutors it would
have been a different story i certainly
think that the difference between the
military
prosecutors and civilian prosecutors
would have changed the outcome of the
case yes and now she's left to carry on
with her career in the military as the
admiral fights to once again be canada's
top commander for me it was very jarring
for me and for him it was
a footnote you know like
he
it is very possible that he doesn't
clearly remember that night but mcdonald
has not heard from the admiral nor has
he apologized i would like
admiral mcdonald to
look into what reconciliation means
and
maybe
if if after
going through that process he he felt
the need to apologize i would welcome it
heather mcdonald is also calling on
parliament and politicians to take
action on the recommendations for change
in the canadian forces instead of
waiting for yet more reports mercedes
stephenson global news victoria
it has been a tough week for the
canadian armed forces more top military
officers have been put on leave while
they're being investigated for alleged
sexual misconduct it comes a week after
prime minister trudeau said the military
just doesn't get it when it comes to
misconduct and as trudeau finalizes who
will be in his new cabinet there are
calls for the defense minister to be
shuffled out of his high profile
portfolio michaela couture reports
major general stephen joseph russell
weyland months after lieutenant general
stephen whalen was installed as the head
of military personnel command he's been
placed on leave amid an allegation of
sexual misconduct
it comes just days after it was revealed
another high-ranking officer lieutenant
general trevor quedier
is also being investigated for alleged
sexual misconduct so for us that have
been in the military for years it
doesn't surprise us that lack of shock
from survivors groups also comes with an
understanding that there are likely more
accusations to come and now people have
that faith in the system that when they
do come forward they're not going to be
railroaded or put into a box that says
this person's a troublemaker and they
make stuff up weyland remained in his
role for months but according to the
canadian armed forces acting chief of
the defense staff general wayne ayer was
notified of the investigation on june
2nd adding whalen was not made aware of
it due to possible impacts on the
investigation the minister of national
defense was informed the same day we
have listened
and we are taking action defense
minister harjit sajan may have this file
on his desk now but that could change
october 26th when prime minister justin
trudeau names his new cabinet
a june report from former supreme court
justice maurice fish found sexual
misconduct in the military is as rampant
now as it was in 2015
the year sajin was named minister his
less affair leadership style has led to
the escalation of those problems and and
just waiting for a review it's not what
we need right now survivors advocates
hope whoever is named minister will
continue to push for a shift within the
military there's lots of great people
left that are in in key leadership
positions
that we're engaged with and
we're looking very positive about
culture change culture change they hope
will lead to a systemic change within
the forces
mike lacrosse global news
prime minister trudeau is traveling to
kamloops bc today the takama loops to
schweitman first nation says he will
visit on monday chief roseanne kasmir
says trudeau passed up two invitations
to visit on september 30th the first
national day for truth and
reconciliation instead he spent the day
on a b.c beach with his wife trudeau
said it was a mistake and he regrets it
the new brunswick government has touched
off controversy by ordering thousands of
provincial employees not to use the
words unseated or unsurrendered when
making public land acknowledgments the
province says it's involved in legal
action over land claims but as ross lord
reports indigenous leaders say it's a
sign of disrespect
in the spirit of reconciliation
indigenous land acknowledgments have
become common in canada thank you for
joining us
virtually here on the traditional
territory of the kuala lum first nation
in the tan quachen council i'm here on
the territories of the musqueam of the
squamish of the slaywoodtooth first
nations
many acknowledge land that was never
surrendered we're coming to you from the
grand hall in the canadian museum of
history on the traditional unseated
territory of the algonquin anishinaabeg
people but the words unseated or
unsurrendered are suddenly a no-no in
new brunswick according to a memo from
the provincial government to thousands
of public servants the province and the
government of canada are being sued by
six first nations communities claiming
more than half of new brunswick's land
mass belongs to them the provincial
government says it's acting strictly
from a legal position they have chosen
to put this issue
before the courts
and that
results in us having no
alternative
but
to
function
as we would
lawyers do what lawyers do the new
brunswick government's replacement
phrasing acknowledges only the ancestral
homelands of indigenous peoples a change
indigenous leaders call deeply
disappointing the alternative that he
has provided is not written by of course
indigenous people to show a respect in
the aftermath of the province's new
position new brunswick rcmp took a stand
on twitter acknowledging the lands on
which new brunswick is situated are the
unseeded and unsurrendered traditional
territory of indigenous peoples
momentum is also growing in the sports
world the montreal canadiens have
committed to acknowledge before every
home game they are on traditional and
unseated territory taking new positions
on an historic grievance at the hockey
rink and in the legal arena
ross lord global news
a canadian is believed to be among 17
missionaries reportedly kidnapped in
haiti this weekend christian aid
ministry says they were on a trip to an
orphanage in the capitol when they were
abducted organizations that monitor
kidnappings in haiti say the
missionaries were taken by a much-feared
violent group jennifer johnson reports
the kidnapped group was part of the
ohio-based christian aid ministries that
has done charity work in haiti for the
past 15 years the missionaries seven
women five men and five children were
leaving an orphanage when they were
abducted the ministry sent out a prayer
alert message confirming the kidnappings
adding pray that the gang members would
come to repentance police believe the
same violent gang that kidnapped five
priests and two nuns in april is also
responsible for saturday's abductions we
need to track down where they are and
and see if you know negotiations without
paying ransom are possible or do
whatever we need to on a military front
or police front one of the missionaries
who was taken reportedly posted a call
for help on whatsapp saying please pray
for us we are being held hostage they
kidnapped our driver pray pray pray we
do not know where they are taking us
haiti is again seeing a surge in gang
violence there was a brief pause after
the assassination of president joe
vanell moise in july
and an earthquake that left more than 2
200 dead in august but there have been
hundreds of kidnappings since including
school children doctors police officers
and busloads of people
with gangs food shortages and political
turmoil overrunning the island nation
haitians are fleeing last month
thousands encamped at the mexico texas
border seeking a better life the u.s
deported most to mexico and flew
thousands of others back to haiti the
u.s special envoy quit in protest
activists continue to call on american
leaders to help the country
congressional elected officials must
appropriate the necessary funds to
rebuild haiti just days ago the u.n and
u.s pledged more aid for haiti's
national police after high-level
officials visited the country but
haitians plan to protest monday decrying
the lack of security and poverty
overwhelming their country
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up a look at the race as voters
in alberta's biggest cities gear up to
elect new mayors
the body of a missing politician in
southeastern alberta has been found and
his wife is now accused in his death
cypress county councilor alfred belye
had been missing since october 8. rcmp
located the 72-year-old's body on friday
they've charged his wife with
second-degree murder and causing an
indignity to a human body
sixty-eight-year-old deborah bellier is
due to appear in provincial court
tomorrow
albertans also go to the polls tomorrow
to choose a new municipal government in
the province's two biggest cities that
means selecting a new mayor as well
calgary mayor nahid nenshi and edmonton
mayor don iverson aren't running for
re-election after a decade of
progressive leadership at both city
halls two conservative candidates are
seeing surging support heather urex west
reports
between alberta premier jason kenney and
the province's two big city mayors there
has been no love lost especially during
covett 19. i have lost any faith in the
ability of the province to do anything
but these adversarial relationships
could soon be reset as both calgary and
edmonton elect new leadership
in calgary the race to replace
nahadnanshi is very close polls show a
two-way race between current city
councilors jeremy farkas and jody
gondeck for me my candidacy it doesn't
fit within the boxes right you know
young socially progressive
financially responsible openly lgbtq
people don't want to look backwards
anymore they want to look forward to a
future that's progressive and
sustainable neck and neck in the polls
the two candidates represent vastly
different visions for city hall jody
gondek has been outspokenly critical of
the provincial government she
has positioning herself in some ways as
you know heir apparent to marnenchi she
shares some of his progressive causes
but during his term on council farkas
has consistently been at odds with the
outgoing mayor he was the only counselor
to vote against the city's recent covet
19 bylaw that made the province's
voluntary vaccine passport program
mandatory for businesses in the city if
farkas wins it's an enormous
positive signal for the kenny government
the edmonton mayor race is seeing
surging support for a conservative
candidate too current city councilor
mike nicol has seen poll numbers climb
in recent weeks as he chases opponent
amarjeet sohi a former liberal cabinet
minister and the front-runner in the
mayoral race there are a lot of
edmontonians out there
you know who are very frustrated who are
very stressed because of the pandemic
you know there's a lot of small
businesses that are really hurting
and nicole's really touching a chord
with them both cities have already seen
a strong voter turnout during advanced
polls as it elects a new mayor and
council in the midst of colvin 19's
punishing fourth wave heather eurex west
global news calgary
ahead world leaders prepare for the cop
26 climate summit but just how high are
the stakes
and just like that cinema has conquered
the cosmos a russian film crew is now
back on earth after making history
shooting the first movie ever shot in
space the movie titled challenge spent
12 days filming on the international
space station and it won't be the last
movie star tom cruise has plans with
nasa to shoot his own hollywood flick in
space in the near future
in two weeks world leaders will gather
in glasgow for the cop 26 conference and
it may be one of the most critical
climate summits in modern history the
meetup aims to move beyond the paris
agreement with ambitious new goals to
slow global warming and limit the
dangerous impact of climate change but
as jackson proskow reports fears are
running high that time is running out
a year of deadly floods severe drought
and wildfires have left little doubt
earth's climate is changing
it's happening so fast the who warns
climate change is now the single biggest
health threat facing humanity we know
very well that climate change is
affecting
the pillars of our health food water
the quality of the air and shelters
against that backdrop the looming cop 26
meeting will seek ambitious new global
targets aimed at limiting the rise in
earth's temperature to 1.5 degrees
celsius where scientists believe the
worst impacts can be avoided
proposed goals include an end date for
the unabated use of coal
making all new cars zero emission within
two decades and ending deforestation by
the end of the 2020s cop26 really is the
the most important opportunity in years
to help put the world on a path to avoid
the worst impacts of the climate crisis
although u.s president joe biden is
attending and prime minister justin
trudeau is expected to go
chinese president xi jinping reportedly
won't be there
china is the world's largest emitter of
greenhouse gases and has hinted it may
rethink its timetable for slashing
emissions and build more coal-fired
power plants amidst an energy shortage i
think
whether or not the president comes or
not i think the key thing to keep an eye
on is what they commit to and what the
actual
delivery and policies look like
promises made are not always promises
kept not a single g20 country is on
track to meet the targets of the 2015
paris accord
this week queen elizabeth was caught on
a hot mic talking about the summit
clearly frustrated with world leaders
climate activists aren't backing down
planning to ramp up the pressure on
leaders who will gather in glasgow
warning the entire world will suffer the
consequences of inaction
jackson prosco global news washington
up next how a montrealer with a spooky
sweet tooth scored a big win at the big
bank
well with halloween fast approaching
it's definitely the season to enjoy
spooky sweets and one montreal baker is
still savoring victory after her big win
on the larger-than-life tv baking
competition the big bake olivia o'malley
has more
kirsten lund is back to business as
usual creating custom cakes for upcoming
weddings and birthdays but this time the
self-employed baker is running on the
feeling of sweet victory
team
whiskey business
we won the 10 grand we won
the title of big big champions so it was
an awesome feeling lund designed her
first cake 12 years ago for her sweet
16. since then she's made thousands of
cakes out of her home in mirabelle the
27 year old says she entered the food
network competition show to challenge
herself it was honestly such a really
cool experience like if we didn't win i
was still so happy with our cake and i
was so proud of my teammates that we
actually got a cake standing in five
hours which is insane because you
literally only have five hours the name
of our cake is monster's playroom the
big big halloween episode's theme was
monster babies lund and her two former
colleagues created a larger-than-life
baby frankenstein cake with a gooey
green potion and jack-in-the-box
frankenstein's bride we have like a kind
of little joke going on in our team that
we all just blacked out because we don't
remember half of it because it goes by
so fast and it's just go go go the
competition was even stressful for her
family
lund didn't tell them she won until they
watched the episode together it was just
phenomenal that the
the
the emotion that we all had you know
that that she actually did it you know
she our little girl did it you know her
family loved the scary yet sweet cake
and so did the judges
kirsten i mean it's so playful the
fondant work is tidy and neat especially
when it came to eating the peanut butter
and jelly chocolate cake
wow lund is looking to enter more
competitions in the future but now she's
planning on using her portion of the
prize money on a well-earned vacation
next year is my 10-year anniversary with
my boyfriend so we are going to greece
olivia o'malley global news montreal
now that we're all hungry that is global
national for this sunday night i'm nitu
garcia tonight your canada is a
bird's-eye view of downtown fredericton
beautiful we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thank you for
watching donna friesen will be back at
the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]